in the lobby of the Ramsay Solutions
headquarters Carson and Bethany are with
us hey guys how are you
we're better than we deserve welcome
welcome here to do a debt-free scream
yes I love it where are you from from
Blair Nebraska just half hour north of
Omaha whoa that's a bit of a halt did
you fly this or drive it we drove it
with all these children that makes it
twice as long how old are the kiddos
Jackson here is four and a half and
Cooper is one and a half all right very
cool so you're here to do your debt-free
scream yep how much have you paid off
paid off 60,000 one hundred seventy six
dollars and 74 cents I love it and how
long did this take you took us 11 days
short of five years five years okay
making what kind of income starting at
33,000 and right now 51,000 way to go
guys very very cool okay so 15,000 a
year dude I'm not doing that right yeah
three of our income went toward paying
off for long you guys have really what
kind of debt was this all student loans
Wow Wow $60,000 in student loans very
cool so the kids got some great t-shirts
on tell people on the radio what they
say oh yeah all right Jackson's wearing
how cash flow can you go and Cooper's
wearing Iowa's cash float which is true
by the way Cooper's have no debt dude
yeah all the way from the beginning from
before the beginning yeah yeah that's
very cool well congratulations you guys
thank you what put you on this journey
five years ago ah when I was in my final
year college before we got married my
sister had your book Total Money
Makeover and I read it in two days and
got hooked and thought I need to get out
of debt and started then
so okay and so Bethenny you come along
in this guy you're dating and marrying
is like in crazy mode he's going to get
out of debt oh man how did that feel
well the first three years of gizelle
intense were intense I mean it was it
was rough I think being content not
having stuff that my friends could have
and not doing stuff that my friends
could do that was probably the hard
part for me um during the whole journey
was finding contentment living in
apartments for seven years I mean oh
we're ready to get out we're ready for a
yard yeah bad and and you know now you
can yes if you don't you got rid of this
thing hanging around your neck yes and
so what are your degrees in I'm a
teacher and Bethany is I'm gonna stay
home on right now if I do have a
teaching degree to okay both of you had
teaching degree so about thirty thousand
each or what roughly about bout down the
middle okay very cool
how's it feel feels awesome Dave it took
I just I think for me the hardest part
was was it just took so long and it just
seemed like halfway through it just was
not gonna be worth it and then to stick
with it and now who are you able to
stick with it cuz five years is forever
it is forever for us it was I mean we
had to stop for both of them we we
stopped just like your plan says and
then cash flowed both there bursts and I
had to get on I didn't want to get a
raise so I got my masters so we cash
flowed that so it really was just
sticking to it and using the budget in a
way that helped both of us rather than
just me the geek understanding it
doesn't he as a team no I think for me
like falling in love with the budget I
think is a necessity and for me for so
long the budget was like this evil
weapon that took away all my fun and I
hated it and then finally falling in
love with a budget and seeing it as a
way to give me freedom was pretty great
yeah what caused that how did that
switch flip from evil budget monster to
you know my friend I think once the
light at the end of the tunnel was
showing it was like okay we can do this
and I I got it
I just gotta kind of white-knuckle it
for a little bit and then it's gonna be
awesome and I think to embrace it as
part of our testimony to to think that
for five years this weight on us is
where bareness down and I think just
like it feels so great to be here and
scream we're debt-free today but in the
same way our weight of sin to Christ has
forgiven us of that and just to embrace
that as part of our Christian testimony
to that this is something we
accomplished but our weight of sin we
could never accomplish without him and
so we're so grateful for how he has led
us on this journey as well and embracing
it as part of our faith to you a good
thing that God calls us to do absolutely
very well said
good job
all right you guys excellent job
so has Jackson been practicing his
debt-free scream Jackson are you gonna
help us yeah let's get this going here
yeah so you guys if you're not watching
these debt free screams on the app at
home you should and watch the streaming
at Dave Ramsey calm as well you can see
all these families and see what's going
on here it's makes a whole big
difference all right here we go Carson
Bethany Jackson Cooper $60,000 paid off
in five years making thirty three
thousand two fifty one thousand count it
down let's hear a great debt free scream
good job counting down Jackson love it
love it love it very well done you guys
that is a blast